Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler du
tourisme éco-responsable ?
C'est une façon de voyager tout en respectant l'environnement.
C'est justement la spécialité de Tolt.
Avec lui, nous partons aujourd'hui
pour un joli périple qui démarre dans le Nord, à Lille,
et qui va nous entraîner jusque
dans la région de Saint-Étienne.
Nous allons découvrir le beffroi de la capitale des Flandres,
le plus haut d'Europe, et nous saurons
enfin si les frites sont françaises ou belges.
Puis nous apprendrons comment se sont formés les méandres de la Loire
et vous verrez que ça souffle aussi pas mal de ce côté.
Je veux parler de la fabrication artisanale du verre.
Attention au départ !
Changer d'air sans émettre de CO2 ou vraiment très peu,
c'est possible avec le vélo et le train.
Sur un Paris-Lille, par exemple,
chaque voyageur émet en moyenne
un kilogramme de CO2 en prenant le train.
En voiture, s'il n'y a qu'un seul passager à bord, eh bien
ces émissions s'élèvent à 23 kilogrammes.
C'est justement en train que Tolt a choisi de se rendre dans la capitale des Flandres.
En plus, Paris-Lille en train, c'est très rapide.
On met beaucoup moins de temps qu'en voiture.
Salut Jamy, je te confirme que c'est plus rapide
puisque le trajet dure très exactement 1h06.
C'est même moins long que de traverser Paris en voiture aux heures de pointe.
Et Lille est très bien desservie par le rail.
On est ici dans une sorte de carrefour.
Mais surtout, il y a ici un réseau régional super efficace
qui permet de découvrir les plages du Nord très rapidement.
On peut aller à Berck, au Touquet ou encore en Baie de Somme.
Avant de découvrir la plage,
il y a Lille et dans la capitale des Flandres,
le monument vers lequel se tournent tous les regards
lorsqu'on sort de la gare, c'est évidemment le beffroi.
Oui, c'est le point de repère pour tous les Lillois.
Le fameux beffroi de l'hôtel de ville.
Regardez s'il n'est pas beau, ce beffroi !
Vu d'en bas, c'est vraiment impressionnant.
Il fait 104 mètres, c'est le plus haut d'Europe.
C'est aussi le symbole de la ville.
On l'appelle d'ailleurs "le gratte-ciel des Flandres".
Il est inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO depuis 2005.
Mais attention, ce n'est pas le seul.
C'est aussi le cas pour 22 autres beffrois dans la région.
Donc, vous l'aurez compris, dans le Nord, on en trouve partout.
Effectivement, les beffrois font partie intégrante du paysage.
La région Hauts-de-France en compte 44.
Leur origine remonte au XIᵉ siècle.
On les érigeait dans les villes qui avaient obtenu leur indépendance vis-à-vis des seigneurs locaux.
Une façon pour ces villes d'affirmer leur puissance.
C'était l'équivalent du donjon.
Ils pouvaient servir de tours de guet, mais pas que !
La plupart possède une cloche au sommet.
Autrefois, elle sonnait régulièrement, entre autres
pour indiquer l'heure aux habitants.
Mais chose très surprenante,
le beffroi de l'hôtel de ville de Lille,
qui est bien plus récent, il a été inauguré en 1932,
n'en possède pas.
En fait, à la fin des travaux, les constructeurs se sont rendu compte
qu'aucune cloche digne de ce nom ne pouvait franchir les portes.
Du coup, c'est le seul beffroi sans cloche.
Même muet, cet édifice est une véritable prouesse architecturale.
C'est le premier bâtiment français de plus de 100 mètres de hauteur,
entièrement réalisé en béton armé.
Pas de cloche, mais un ascenseur qui, de toute façon,
ne servira pas à Tolt puisqu'il se déplace en train, à vélo et à pied.
Allez, encore un petit effort !
398, 399, 400 ! Et voilà.
Nous voici enfin arrivés en haut des 400 marches du beffroi.
C'est assez sportif, mais honnêtement, ça vaut le coup.
Regardez-moi cette vue !
J'arrête pas de voir des gens manger, ça m'a ouvert l'appétit.
Et ce qui est cool à Lille, c'est qu'il y a plein de bonnes adresses.
Mais aujourd'hui, je n'ai pas envie de vous emmener dans un restaurant.
J'ai envie de vous emmener dans un festival de food truck.
Comme c'est un peu loin,
On va prendre un taxi.
Non, je plaisante ! Vous me connaissez.
On va y aller à vélo !
Il y a des vélos en libre-service à Lille,
mais comme on va devoir sortir de la ville en fin de journée,
on va plutôt passer par un loueur traditionnel.
Ici, de plus en plus de gens utilisent ce mode de locomotion
pour se déplacer.
Il faut dire que la municipalité fait tout
pour faciliter l'accès au vélo.
Lille veut faire partie du peloton de tête
des plus grandes agglomérations cyclables de France.
Elle compte d'ailleurs déjà plus de 150 km de pistes
réservées aux vélos.
Me voilà arrivé devant un bâtiment assez impressionnant
puisqu'il s'agit d'une ancienne manufacture textile.
Aujourd'hui, c'est l'un des plus grands incubateurs
de start-up d'Europe.
Je n'ai jamais vu autant de food trucks !
Le but, c'est de faire découvrir la cuisine du monde aux Lillois.
On trouve ici des tacos, des burgers et aussi des ramen,
un plat japonais à base de nouilles.
Mais évidemment, nous sommes à Lille et ici, le plat incontournable, ce sont les frites.
Et ça tombe bien, j'ai rendez-vous avec le chef Florent Ladeyn.
Il paraît que ses frites sont les meilleures de la région !
Bon alors, t'as choisi quelle variété de pommes de terre
pour faire tes frites ?
Et surtout pourquoi ?
Alors là, on est sur une variété très locale qui est produite en plus
par Joseph, le voisin qui m'a tenu dans les bras
quand j'étais petit.
C'est la Bintje parce qu'en ce moment, c'est la meilleure.
C'est quoi justement ta recette à toi ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'elle est si spéciale ?
Nous, notre secret, c'est de rien inventer et de rien
changer à la tradition.
C'est de respecter le fait de faire
les frites au gras de bœuf, de les faire en deux cuissons,
un premier bain à 130 degrés à la cool
pour rendre la pomme de terre purée et un deuxième bain à température plus élevée pour vraiment saisir,
pour avoir la croustillance.
Parce qu'une bonne frite, c'est de la purée au cœur,
mais de la croustillance.
Alors, dernière question pour finir qui,
peut-être, fâche un peu...
Selon toi, les frites c'est belge ou c'est français ?
Je ne peux pas me faire de potes
là-dessus parce que moi, je suis flamand de France.
J'ai grandi sur la frontière
et je pense que ça a été créé à un endroit où la frontière
franco-belge n'était pas aussi définie et dessinée qu'aujourd'hui.
Bon Florent, il ne veut pas trop se mouiller visiblement.
Et toi Jamy, t’en penses quoi ?
Pour nous, Français,
c'est évident, les frites viennent de France,
mais pour les Belges, elles sont belges.
Alors qui a tort ? Qui a raison ? Les deux, mon capitaine !
Les frites auraient été inventées au XVIIᵉ siècle
dans la ville de Namur, à 70 kilomètres au sud de Bruxelles.
Pour leur repas, les habitants de cette ville avaient l'habitude
de faire frire du poisson qu'ils pêchaient dans la Meuse.
Mais lors d'un hiver particulièrement rigoureux,
la Meuse a gelé.
Impossible de pêcher.
Les Namurois auraient alors eu une idée de génie :
remplacer les poissons par des pommes de terre découpées en bâtonnets.
Des pommes de terre frites elles aussi.
Voilà comment les Belges auraient inventé les frites.
Excuse-moi Jamy, mais moi, il me semble avoir
entendu que la frite avait vu le jour à Paris.
J'y viens.
Cette histoire de Meuse gelée et de pommes de terre frites
pour remplacer les poissons n'a jamais été prouvée.
D'ailleurs, elle tiendrait davantage de la légende.
Selon certains historiens, elles auraient en effet été inventées sur les bords de la Seine
à la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle ou au début du XIXᵉ.
À l'époque sur le Pont-Neuf,
des vendeuses ont l'idée de tremper des pommes de terre
découpées en rondelles dans une friture de saindoux.
Elles vendent leur savoureuses pommes du Pont-Neuf
aux spectateurs des nombreux théâtres installés dans le quartier.
On dit que Baudelaire et Victor Hugo en raffolaient.
Après les années 30,
on finit par abandonner les rondelles au profit des bâtonnets,
bien plus pratiques car ils ne collent pas entre eux à la cuisson.
C'est donc bien en France que sont nées les frites telles que nous les connaissons aujourd'hui.
Il ne faut pas négliger le rôle joué par les Belges.
Ce sont eux qui ont rendu les frites célèbres dans le monde entier.
Grâce
à un Allemand !
Un certain Jean-Frédéric Krieger.
Ce forain, originaire de Bavière, ouvre
la première baraque à frites de Belgique en 1844.
Il y propose des pommes de terre frites à la parisienne.
Surnommé le roi de la frite, il rencontre un succès fou dans toutes les foires du plat pays
et très vite, les frites deviennent un classique de la cuisine belge.
En résumé, ce sont donc les Français qui ont inventé les frites,
mais ce sont les Belges qui les ont rendues célèbres dans le monde entier.
Allez, direction la forêt de Phalempin.
Je n'y vais pas pour ramasser les champignons.
C'est là-bas que je vais passer la nuit.
Mais avant ça, je vais regarder l'itinéraire sur mon application.
Ça permet de trouver le meilleur itinéraire pour les vélos
en me faisant passer par un
maximum de voies aménagées.
Ah oui, quand même.
1h22 ! Bon bah, on va y aller peut-être ?
Vous allez voir, j'ai réservé un hébergement pas comme les autres.
Une énorme cabane perchée à huit mètres de hauteur.
Bon, évidemment, il ne faut pas trop avoir le vertige.
Ici, pas de douche,
juste des toilettes sèches
et un grand lit avec vue sur la forêt.
Avec un peu de chance,
je pourrais peut-être voir un chevreuil,
un renard ou même un écureuil.
Ah, je sens que je vais passer une bonne nuit !
Et ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose
parce que demain, j'ai rendez-vous du côté de Saint-Etienne
pour découvrir les gorges de la Loire.
Au programme, on a deux TGV et un TER à prendre.
Et cette fois-ci, je vais pouvoir embarquer mon vélo.
Mais en tout cas, j'ai hâte de découvrir ces paysages.
Autrefois, les vélos étaient considérés comme de simples bagages dans le train.
On les transportait gratuitement dans des wagons prévus à cet effet.
En 1898, certains jours,
on a pu enregistrer jusqu'à 3000 bicyclettes
dans les gares parisiennes, un record !
Mais tout change un siècle plus tard.
Dans les années 1970, ces fameux wagons sont peu à peu supprimés
et les guichets à bagages ferment les uns après les autres.
Le service est définitivement supprimé en 1998.
Cette décision provoque un véritable tollé.
Les associations de cyclistes se mobilisent
auprès de la SNCF
afin qu'un service soit rétabli au plus vite.
Aujourd'hui, il est donc à nouveau possible d'emporter avec soi
son vélo sur la plupart des trajets, à une condition :
il doit être démonté et rangé dans une housse, comme un simple bagage.
Si votre bicyclette ne se démonte pas, sachez cependant
qu'il existe des espaces prévus à cet effet,
mais uniquement dans certains TGV et TER.
Renseignez-vous avant de partir.
On y suspend son vélo à un crochet,
ça prend moins de place.
Si comme moi, vous voulez voyager en train avec votre vélo,
l'option vous coûtera 10€ dans un TGV.
Mais sinon, dans ce TER de Lyon à Saint-Etienne, c'est gratuit.
Voilà, maintenant, j'ai plus qu'une grosse heure de vélo
pour rejoindre Saint-Victor-sur-Loire.
Vous allez voir : les panoramas sont à couper le souffle !
J'arrive sur le piton rocheux du Plateau de la Danse.
Attention, il faut pousser son vélo sur les derniers mètres.
Mais franchement, c'est le meilleur spot
pour découvrir les gorges de la Loire.
Franchement, c'est pas trop beau ?
Vous voyez, ici, le paysage est super contrasté.
On peut voir des forêts, des falaises, des landes.
Un peu plus loin, là-bas, on a le port
de Saint-Victor-sur-Loire
et encore plus loin,
on peut apercevoir le château de Grangent,
perché sur son île.
Et là-bas, là-haut, c'est le château d'Essalois.
Franchement, c'est à tomber !
Fais attention à toi quand même !
Ces gorges offrent un panorama unique.
Elles s'étirent sur 24 kilomètres,
depuis Aurec-sur-Loire jusqu'à Saint-Just-Saint-Rambert.
Elles ont été creusées par le fleuve pendant des millions d'années.
Il s'est frayé un passage dans le plateau granitique
qui sépare les monts du Forez et le massif du Pilat.
C'est une très vieille chaîne de montagnes formée
il y a 300 millions d'années : la chaîne hercynienne.
La Loire y a sculpté ses méandres et creusé son cours,
parfois sur plusieurs centaines de mètres.
Au milieu du XXᵉ siècle,
le paysage a été transformé par la construction
du barrage hydroélectrique de Grangent.
Le mur de béton de 55 mètres de hauteur barre la Loire
et forme une retenue qui s'étend sur 400 hectares.
Presque 400 terrains de football.
Elle s'étire sur 21 kilomètres.
Cette opération a englouti les anciens ponts, les viaducs et les voies ferrées.
Désormais, les gorges de la Loire ont un petit air de fjord forézien.
Pour les arpenter, il existe plus de 50 itinéraires de randonnées pédestres signalisés.
Des circuits qui vont d'une heure à 6h de marche.
Sinon, vous pouvez faire comme Tolt,
utiliser des pistes vertes qui ont été
balisées pour circuler à VTT.
J'ai quitté les gorges pour Saint-Galmier, la ville qui pétille.
Et pour cause, c'est ici
qu'on trouve la source d'une célèbre eau pétillante minérale.
Elle est mise en bouteille ici-même depuis 1837.
Saint-Galmier se situe au cœur du Massif central,
à la croisée des monts du Lyonnais et de la plaine du Forez.
Et vous allez voir qu'ici, on ne produit pas que de l'eau.
L'attraction à ne pas louper, c'est l'atelier de Pierre Marion.
Il est souffleur de verre ou plus précisément de cristal.
Mais bon, pas le temps de souffler,
je vais aller lui rendre une petite visite.
- Bonjour Tolt.
- Comment ça va ?
- Bien, bien.
Bon, alors là, on est dans ton atelier en plein air où tu confectionnes
des pièces à partir de cristal recyclé.
C'est les pièces qu'on voit là-bas, sur les étagères.
Est-ce que tu peux nous en dire
un peu plus sur les outils que tu utilises ?
Alors, c'est le four, bien sûr, puisque c'est là où se trouve la matière en fusion,
les outils, c'est les cannes pour souffler les pièces.
C'est une canne, un tube en métal, en inox
et le bout de la canne
qu'on appelle le mors de la canne,
lui est en acier réfractaire, justement pour supporter
des températures bien élevées,
de l'ordre de 1200 degrés.
Alors, est-ce que tu peux nous décrire
un peu plus précisément la canne à souffler ?
- Quelle taille elle fait, quel diamètre ?
- C'est un peu comme une sarbacane,
donc ça fait à peu près 1 cm, 1,5 cm
maximum de diamètre
et en longueur, ça fait 1m20 à peu près.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer pas à pas tout
le processus de création d'une pièce ?
Alors on prend déjà une canne.
Si on veut faire une pièce colorée,
on met un morceau de couleur au bout de la canne,
on le fait fondre, on souffle un peu dans la canne pour introduire déjà une toute petite bulle d'air.
On appelle ça une poste. On la laisse refroidir,
après on va la plonger dans un bain de cristal
en fusion, qui est à peu près à 1100-1150 degrés.
Après, donc, on recouvre cette poste de couleur
avec une couche de cristal transparent.
On le centre à nouveau, ce cristal transparent, autour
de cette poste de couleur, on la laisse devenir un peu rigide
et on va prendre des morceaux de couleur qu'on va ajouter
par endroits sur cette masse de cristal transparent.
On va retourner à nouveau dans le four de fusion où se trouve le cristal transparent
pour remettre une couche de cristal par-dessus.
Ça permet d'avoir plus de matière toutes ces couches.
Donc on peut mettre en fait cinq ou six couches de cristal
les unes sur les autres.
Il ne faut pas en mettre plus après
parce que tu n'arrives plus à le porter !
À moins d'être très costaud !
Et ensuite seulement, on souffle le verre.
Une fois qu'elle est terminée, on ne peut pas la laisser refroidir comme ça à l'air libre
ou dans l'atelier, elle casserait.
Il y a encore un autre four qu'on appelle le four
de re-cuisson
et c'est pendant la nuit que les pièces vont refroidir tout doucement.
On les sort seulement le lendemain
et certaines pièces très épaisses,
ça peut nécessiter plus de 24 h pour refroidir.
Figurez-vous que les pièces de cristal soufflées par Pierre
séduisent bien au-delà de la région
puisque même Madonna, la reine de la pop, lui a commandé plusieurs flacons comme celui-ci.
La classe, non ?
Le cristal a été mis au point au XVIIᵉ siècle
par un marchand verrier anglais, George Ravenscroft.
Il aurait découvert ce nouveau matériau par hasard
en ajoutant de l'oxyde de plomb dans la recette du verre.
Le verre est obtenu en faisant fondre du sable, de
la silice précisément, à laquelle on ajoute de la soude
afin de faire baisser la température de fusion.
En ajoutant de l'oxyde de plomb et en faisant cuire ce mélange
pendant au moins 36h à 1450 degrés,
on obtient du cristal.
Ce matériau possède une densité plus élevée que le verre.
Il est aussi plus dur et en prime, il a un éclat extraordinaire.
Voilà, Jamy, j'arrive au bout de mon périple
et ce soir, je dors dans un château. Chic, non ?
J'ai parcouru plus de 1400 kilomètres
entre Paris, Lille et Saint-Etienne
et je suis super fier de moi parce que
j'ai réussi à émettre à peu près 50 fois moins
de gaz à effet de serre que si j'avais pris la voiture.
Jamy, la prochaine fois, tu viens avec moi ?
Avec grand plaisir Tolt !
Je prendrais peut-être mon vélo électrique.
Voilà, j'espère que notre petit périple à la découverte
des trésors de Lille et de la région
de Saint-Étienne vous a plu.
Surtout, qu'il vous a convaincu qu'on peut faire de beaux voyages
et de très belles rencontres tout en respectant l'environnement.
Je vous dis à la semaine prochaine et d'ici-là,
passez d'excellents moments sur les réseaux avec les Épicurieux !